but first we have breaking news coming
in from Britain and the Prime Minister
Rishi sunak has fired the conservative
party chairman from the government the
move comes after an independent
investigation into Nadeem zahawi's tax
Affairs found a serious breach of the
ministerial code sunak ordered the probe
last week after facing pressure over the
issue we'll get more on this from Nadine
Papa he's joining us from London so what
exactly do we know about how and and why
this happened
we know that um it's happened
um unusually quickly if you like after
an investigation ordered just a few days
ago by prime minister Rishi sunak asking
uh Solari Magnus his ethics advisor to
look into
reports of a dispute between the Tory
party chair Nadeem zahawi and Her
Majesty's revenue and Customs reports
that Mr zahawi had paid a penalty uh
which was part of a reported six million
dollar settlement
just about a week and a half ago the
Prime Minister was in Parliament saying
that Mr zahawi had dealt with the matter
in full and then prime minister's
questions this week
um it was a different story uh hints
that in fact Mr zahawi had known when he
was appointed Chancellor last year to
Liz truss's government and then to um a
subsequent government that he he knew
that there was a dispute with the tax
authorities now the letter uh to Mr
zahawi on Sunday from the Prime Minister
says when I became prime minister last
year I pledged that the government I led
would have integrity professionalism and
accountability at every level and
although he pays tribute to Mrs zahoe's
role as vaccines Minister he basically
says look I have no alternative but to
SACU between the lines you didn't tell
me everything that you knew before I
told the world that there was nothing to
see here now um specifically the the um
the investigation and there's a a
four-page document dated Sunday uh it
says that Mr zahari failed to declare
that hmrc the tax authorities were
investigating his taxes as a conflict of
interest when he became Chancellor and
he also failed to declare that he'd paid
a penalty fine when he was appointed to
his position last year now even before
today uh the labor opposition and some
uh ex-tory ministers have said that uh
Rishi sunac should have got rid of Mr
zahawi in the pre previous days because
it was clear that um there had been an
investigation and that he hadn't
declared that right so Nadeem let me ask
you this then what does this exactly
mean for us for sunak and and for the
government going forward
yeah I think you're asking about the
implications there well obviously Mr
sunac has talked about an ethical
government things are not looking great
because there's not only that there's
the other um growing controversy over
what happened with Boris Johnson the
previous prime minister and the now
chair of the BBC the British
Broadcasting Corporation uh Richard
Sharp there's a new memo which is
printed in today's press which um
reportedly says and it's from the uh the
cabinet secretary to Boris Johnson
saying giving given the imminent
announcement of Richard sharper's new
BBC chair it's important that you no
longer ask his advice about your
personal financial matters that was just
a couple of weeks before Richard shop
was appointed BBC Chair by prime
minister Boris Johnson Boris Johnson did
get a loan facility of around a million
dollars both Johnson and sharp say
nothing untoward happened but at the
moment there are growing uh worries for
which you soon act to deal with just
like previous administrations got
distracted by this kind of problem thank
you so much Nadeem Baba for that
reporting from London